[Applause]
all right here we are on CNN your home
her who directed Road produced and
starred in the new movie Somewhere in
Queens Ray Romano is over here it's on
Hulu I loved it she is the anchor of
CNN's Laura coach live you all know
Laura coach okay your big star and
novelist and coost of the America this
week podcast Walter ker was as funny as
ever
tonight okay so these uh I hold in my
hand the uh the are the people write in
and here are their questions we don't
know what they are what does the panel
think of Oprah revealing she used a
weight loss drug how dramatically will
drugs like OIC impact the Obesity
epidemic in America well it's already
happened it's already you know and I
think Oprah was very complimentary about
OIC right already was I knew she'd used
a drug because she kept the weight off
um it seems like every other Oprah diet
hasn't worked so it had to be something
right right I think Oprah looks
wonderful and I but I will say I'm glad
that she's talking about the lack of
that there should not be shame
associated with what people are doing um
however you
know it it's going to turn into you get
nopic and you get one and you get one
different
story can I ask a question please do are
we okay with OIC is there what's the
downside well we don't know yet
yeah I'm hearing good I mean I hear good
things and that it's not only going to
be useful for uh weight loss but but
addiction I mean it does something to
your brain I I don't know I mean would I
use it no I I don't and you use
everything
right and I am and I am a a a drug
offici yes you're
right uh Ray this is for you do you
think a show like everybody loves rain
women that appealed to people all over
the political Spectrum would be
successful today in our polarized
country I going be more successful I
mean it's what this country
needs and here I am answering for
you it's hard to say I mean the
landscape has changed TV has changed and
and live live sitcom in front of an
audience is kind of a a throwback thing
but I think at the end funny is funny if
it's done right I think I think it can
survive if if you do it right I'm much
more worried about standup I mean stand
up yeah yeah I mean somebody my friend
we both know was telling me about uh
performing recently at some place and
there was like uh mostly Millennials and
she goes into her act and she's
hysterically funny and she said there
was this like feeling of like oh the old
person is doing
jokes that's like corny now jokes are
corny Ray don't tell tell jokes it's
corny well I still go to the clubs I
when I'm in New York I go to the and
please keeps telling jokes they're funny
yeah don't don't let the Millennials
dissuade
you the next time you got to tell them
in acronyms you got to do the whole bit
and just TT y l f MF whatever it is yeah
it'll be a day where they don't laugh
they just go LOL LOL
LOL that's what you got to worry
about right
okay see you are good at this how will
sh otani's Landmark $700 million deal
with the Dodgers change baseball in
professional sports I don't know if
it'll change it it's it's just always
moving up yeah it's always been going
that's why I invested in the Mets when I
did when people say you're crazy why you
why are you buying a piece of a baseball
team I said because Sports is the one
thing that always goes up and it's the
because I did a piece on this one week
it's the one thing you can trust it's
the one because I know that that those
people who play baseball those are the
absolute best 600 baseball players in
the world there is no favoritism there's
no nepo babies in sports you just got to
show up and do the
best
and you
know if if if LeBron James kid isn't
good he won't play as great a story as
that is he won't play it's change
otani's changing the sport by being a
double an athlete who can pitch and hit
I mean that's un
so well Babe Ruth did it yeah but and
that's it right right yeah so you're
saying there was a
gap I this this may be an outlier
opinion on this but I think because I
think the way athletes Elite athletes
work it's a mental thing you know when
nobody broke the four-minute mile and
then one guy did and everybody did right
I think that'll happen with for with
this too I think there will be other
people who hit and Pitch well that's
what that's why he's going to change
that's how it's going to change oh right
yes well I got news for you it's you'll
always be the outlier when you can
invest in a sports team
um absolutely maybe I am richer than
you
ging but you know what's changing if
that is the amount of the contract that
explains the $25 hot
dog is there really a $25 h i mean it's
like you get a hot dog you get a soda
you may get a pretzel the Cracker Jack
is not even like a real toy it's paper I
mean it's a whole thing right the whole
thing now no I I never understand the
American economy I I don't like Taylor
Swift tickets I read somewhere that the
average spent on the Taylor is $1,300
now that includes like travel and
merchand but like like that many people
have that much money to waste I mean can
you imagine going to they don't have
that much money to waste they beg borrow
they charge up their credit card yeah
I think they get it from their parents
right they get it from their parents and
then they turn into Hunter Biden later
because boy 400
b uh Laura what do you think of Jack
Smith taking Trump's immunity claim
directly to the Supreme Court brilliant
why not I mean why you go straight to
the horse's mouth I mean or nine of them
I mean what you're going to have to have
a time when you know what's ending up in
this Supreme Court so why go through all
the raro and met cutest route just give
me the answer is he immune or not do I
have a case is there a trial in March no
Ray claims he's not smart enough to do
this show but he plainly is just pretend
he isn't and explain the background of
this right dumb it down dumb it down not
dumb it down but but I mean people may
not have heard about immunity and I'm a
little fuzzy on this too so you so so
Jack and Jill went up a hill and then
they
um
no honestly here's what happen really
it's this remember that statement by
Nixon if the president does it it's not
illegal right remember that Sten well
everything a president does is not an
official presidential act going to the
bathroom campaigning cre a crime these
aren't things that are in the real house
of a president in the same respect so
they're trying to figure out if it's not
what your official duty is do you get
the protection of being able to say you
can't touch me you can't prosecute me CU
everything doing is part of the job
that's the immunity issue which of his
four trials does this pertain to this
pertains to the January 6th trial in
Washington DC the big one the federal
trial about election subversion he's
trying to claim that everything he said
leading up to January 6th and really on
January 6 was all part of a presidential
Duty and therefore I can't be prosecuted
you got to know the answer to that
question before you go forward with the
trial because if he's right and if the
court sides with him a lot of these
cases at the federal level go poof gone
I saw today that Trump is beating Biden
by 10 points 48 to 38 and only last
month Biden was up by four he lost 14
points in a month and it's a month where
the economy seemed to be getting better
it seemed like inflation is getting more
under control the stock market just h a
record high what what what was the
14-point loss about it can't all be
Hunter Biden I know we love to pile on
Hunter Biden but I don't know I feel
like people talk about um the F inomics
right how I feel about something more
than what the actual data is and I'm far
from my you know home turf talking about
inflation and everything else I know how
much milk costs I know how much M gas
costs I know how I feel about both but
people are not always on board and
saying you might be telling me all the
wins you have but if I don't feel like
I'm winning then I'm not winning and you
won't either I
also so willle me this I saw in the
paper this week that somebody asked
Biden if they thought he was the only
one who could beat Trump which I always
thought was the whole reason why this
person who I like Joe but I don't think
he should be the candidate but I thought
that that's the whole R onrea for the he
said yeah think about 50 he said he
thought 50 Democrats could beat Trump
then why are you
there who do we and why name one who is
the one you think that can be I well as
James Carville said he said any Centrist
Democrat like 50ish a lot of it an age
thing uh could do it and I kind of agree
and Gavin nome's going to be on our
first
show it looks like pretty strong
candidate to me all right we got to go
thank you very oh I'm sorry did you want
to I was going to say everybody loves
Ray
oh we like him too much for that thank
you everybody see you next one
time